so um the takeaways that I expect to
give you from this talk is definitely uh
what is data drift what are its common
types how it's detected a very small
piece of python code uh that I just put
together uh to see that how drift would
look and how it can be detected with
very basic test and then okay drift
happened and your team got it what to do
about it and also because language
models they are the Talk of the Town so
then what does drift uh look like for
unstructured data like
text first of all a little about myself
uh I'm leading the research at centus
Inc and why I'm here to talk about data
drift is that for past more than one
year I have been working with mlops and
llm Ops and U I've been interacting with
many practitioners in industry and our
potential clients they have a lot of
concerns and I see that data drift is
one of the most common concerns that we
have been seeing and it is still one of
the major causes for silent failure of
models uh I would be open to
collaboration discussion like you can
block my calendar and we can talk over a
coffee online so feel free to connect on
LinkedIn and Twitter so hopping on to
quickly uh why models fail and I'm sure
you must have seen at least one of these
four major categories uh first is
definitely data and I'm so tired of the
saying that garbage in garbage out but
it is the truth so any changes in data
collection or pre-processing or if
something gets missed out uh that can
cause issues then uh the model itself uh
is the one that can uh introduce errors
or it might not be you might not have
been able to translate your business
objectives to the model performance so
again this is one issue uh I've also
seen that uh there is a little less
understanding about how models need to
be validated or what kind of performance
metrics need to be used so all these
they come under the model issue uh
umbrella then definitely drifts again
I've just written data drift concept but
there are like coari also so it's there
lastly regulatory so your models are
talking with people and they should not
be favoring a particular class when
making decisions so again bias fairness
of non-compliance when it comes to
privacy and transparency those are also
some Factor
that can throw off your model uh but for
now and for this talk uh let's focus on
data drift so what exactly is data drift
um there is a data set that you use to
train your model or you validate it with
another set and you test it out and off
it goes it has deployed so while your
model uh is sitting behind a service and
users are interacting with it uh people
change their behavior changes or it
might be that the data that's coming in
uh its distribution can change so I've
thrown in a bit of mats here the pro The
Joint probability distribution for the
Model Behavior and how it would look
based on the relationship between the uh
input X and input y so what is data
drift data drift is commonly when uh the
probability distribution of input
changes with time so what the model had
known during its training and testing
phase that it is no longer it no longer
holds a model is no longer able to
identify the distribution that is now
coming from the live data uh and there's
another kind of data drift that's called
a label shift so over here uh the
distribution of output changes but the
difference from concept drift is that
the relationship between the input and
output Remains the Same so uh for
instance uh let's take a study of uh
bird population in a city so with
weather it can change so while the
distribution of the count of birds and
that is being predicted it might change
uh with seasonal shift but then uh the
relationship will remain same that in
Spring there would be more birds and in
Winters there would be lesser birds so
over here we are seeing a label shift uh
if I bring uh come on to a more serious
topic um if we talk about drug test so
uh we have certain age group
and if we are um predicting uh what is
the probability of getting breast cancer
so unfortunately females uh who are
above 40 they are more prone to getting
breast cancer so there is a relationship
between these age classes and the output
of u a positive prognosis so then U
suppose a drug is being tested and uh
now people are seeing better change in
the disease so uh the number is coming
down for the disease detection that okay
the uh the breast cancer prognosis it's
going down so your output distribution
is changing but again the relationship
between the age bracket and the breast
cancer probability it Remains the Same
so this is called uh label
shift so why does it happen it can
happen like I and my team have primarily
identified four major factors uh first
is definitely it could be a bug or some
oversight on data quality maybe more
noises coming in now when we are when
the model is facing the live environment
uh there could be a feature change uh
for instance U if the age had been
recorded in months and now it is decided
that let's collect age in terms of year
so again there's a major shift in the
distribution of the values that we see
then Upstream process changes uh these
can be as simple as uh publishing your
service to different geography or
different demography so again uh your
service it would see a difference in
user Behavior and the patterns which
might lead to a change in the
distribution of the incoming data and
the model that is sitting behind the
service it was used to some other
Behavior or other patterns and now it's
seeing a difference and fourthly
definitely time because training data it
can become obsolete so uh let's take a
sales for
and if it has been rained on data that
was maybe year or two years old then it
would no longer be um relevant if we
talk about now so definitely drift does
happen it is not inevitable it is
inevitable sorry and it's just that uh
data drift is there but when to uh call
it a violation or when to call it a an
alarming situation this is where the
definition comes
in so I would say k them young there are
certain tests that are there to see that
okay the distribution is Shifting so how
can we detect it early on so a point
that I missed here is that there are
four types of drifts uh one is uh it is
gradually it happens slowly and then
there are sudden shifts very sudden you
will see a very uh sharp rise or sharp
fall in the
distribution then there's incremental
one where the new distribution very
slowly
it takes over the original ship so you
would see original distribution then a
bit of new distribution then original
then more of new and slowly slowly the
new distribution takes over and lastly
is seasonal so as I'm talking about
birds and maybe shopping Behavior Uh for
instance like Thanksgiving Christmas it
again sees it can see a drastic shift so
this is uh seasonal shift so uh again uh
coming back to how we detect shifts uh
sometimes it's very simple that you can
look into the statistics uh and maybe
see quantize or see the skilless of the
data or its variance median that how it
was for particular time frame for three
months for 6 months and then compare it
to your current live incoming data then
two sample tests are very popular among
industry and my team has also been
implementing them so uh it is very
simple from the name to sample so we
have different if we come down to
statistics we have two populations we
draw samples and we just check that
whether uh the two distributions whether
they agree whether there's a similarity
between them and we use certain
confidence with that hypothesis so same
happens here just that the two samples
are one is from the training data set
and the other sample is from the live
data and we just run these test to see
that okay uh the null hypothesis is that
these these two samples are coming from
the same kind of distribution and if the
P value or it does not agree then we say
that okay there has been a change there
has been a drift and it's not always P
value it can also be Divergence value
when we are talking about gensen Channel
and again K Divergence is also there and
then we have Earth movers distance as
well so uh there are numerous metrics
that you can use so how is it decided
I'll cover in coming slides uh while I
was talking about the sample test they
work uh for very well for data that is
not too large Dimension uh if you come
down to large Dimension data set then
I've seen personally like some of
potential clients have also mentioned
that rather than getting alerted on each
and every feature it would be so
annoying for them so instead of that uh
they would rather have a percentage
share of features so for instance if
they have 400 features uh so they might
might just specify that okay alert is if
20% of all features they show a drift of
30% so um 50 uh features drifting U 100
features drifting so now we are putting
a count to it we not saying that look
for each individual feature since it's a
large Dimension data go for a percentage
share and just
raise that okay there's a drift if a
particular share has seen drift
so this is a small part of logic that my
team is using uh for data D detection
this is just a small part that when we
use what if it's a numerical data a
numerical feature sorry then what kind
of test we would use and again the
cardinality or you can say the number of
unique values in the set it plays a
significant role when you're going for
the test so uh let's take the second
point that uh if it's aad orical feature
and it could be something simple like if
the survey takes it as gender so male
female other because people tend to Club
it so then it's a very small garden
ality uh whereas if we go forward uh
with race again it can be a large number
or it could be a age itself also it can
be greater than five if we take age
brackets so then uh the preferred test
uh that we can move
on another kind of test
uh if it's lesser than five then go for
k k
squ so I also put together a small a
very small piece of code to show that
how uh
sorry so I will be be sharing the link
for this uh notebook so that you guys
can also try and I put the link for the
data set also that I used Dow Jones one
and uh I focused on price which is a
numerical feature and it holds
uh it holds large number of values large
number of unique values so uh just a
brief uh view of what the data set looks
like and I've already run it so I not
run again just in case run some error
so this is how I simulated the drift you
can pick this function for your own
testing uh so how drift is being
introduced is from like we have taken
last one year of data from the
DAT and introduce the drift in the
middle so uh there is the position of
the data and the
magnitude so0 five is uh it means that
start from the middle of the data set
that's under focus and size is like go
100% go white so if you can change this
you can change it to 0.2 0.4 and 0.5 as
per your choice drift was
introduced so this is what the drift
looked
like while the original distribution was
like
this so coming down to I uh the test I
used a very simple test the movers
distance of ss distance and uh as you
can see it's giving a very large value
so I had created a copy and in one I had
introduced the drift the other is the
original one and it's very high value
because we have seen values up to 1.5
1.75 which is a decent comparison
between uh two samples from similar
distribution so it definitely says that
okay there's a huge difference and if it
is this huge value then definitely
something's wrong so you can put a check
on this you can put alert on this and no
not okay anything above 1.75 or at Max
if you want to go till 10 or 15 that's
fine but anything above that raise an
alarm uh I also showed one example for
KS test again KS test it assumes normal
distribution which we are not seeing
here and that's why I didn't give the
good results uh just to show you that it
won't work in this case uh I have also
added a link to a very nice article by
evidently where they have compared five
different kinds of test for data dri
dete
okay okay so once you have detected data
drift then what what can your team team
do so so One does not simply hit the bre
button that should be a decision after a
lot of analysis and once uh it the
decision has to be thoroughly backed by
a couple of
steps so first of all is the data drift
a symptom for a bigger problem so pull
out your logs see if there were any
errors there or definitely uh you should
watch out for data Integrity you
[Music]
should for any outliers or any out of
range values so such data Integrity
issues can can again cause the data
drift uh and definitely unknown values
or outliers they show uh that okay you
were not prepared to go beyond a certain
range so definitely look into these
problems uh before hitting the retrain
button or change for look for the
pattern changes that okay did the
business problem change did the
demography change geography changed like
the service how has it how has it used
changed over time uh when we were seeing
like three months back it maybe there
has been some change in it maybe it has
been floated to a different set of users
so definitely look into those aspects as
well then read the plots of drifted
features like I showed a very simple uh
line graph but you can definitely think
of more creative ways to see how the
features are drifting uh on based on
different time window values uh also uh
plotting the correlation of the
particular drifted feature with uh model
predictions that also really helps well
it's very tiny I put the graph over here
just for the context that how number of
page views for a website uh how the
correlation uh change was pretty
significant uh another way you can also
do is uh you can plot heat maps for the
singular analysis between the
feature and the model prediction so that
can also give you a quick view of how
the correlation has changed between the
two and uh definitely uh if you can
afford to you can you must wait and
watch and see if your model is adapting
to the drift so uh main purpose is to
see if your model's performance metric
if it's fluctuating if it's fluctuating
too badly uh if it is going down uh then
uh okay first of all if it's able to
adapt your performance metric is not
going bad uh your model is adapting fine
to this change congratulations you buil
a somewh robust model uh so hydrate and
carry on otherwise yes please hit the
retrain button so a couple of things
also uh I'm not talking about just
retraining with the new set of data the
live data that has been picked up maybe
from last three months six months uh you
can also uh like if you see that okay
again it is not cause it is not causing
any improvements uh sometimes teams have
to recalibrate the model itself uh to to
make it more robust to make it more
adaptable to Future drifts so that is
one uh also one
option uh another thing that we also
offer for better analysis or deeper dive
into these changing U patterns is uh if
you're seeing a couple of features that
are drifting a lot then uh create a Subs
segment or a cohort of weekly performing
features just make this Subs segment
like if if it's a health data set then
uh you can make a Subs segment of maybe
females who are between the age of 25
and 30 who have never been pregnant uh
make this sub segment and then check out
that okay what's what's the problem
maybe it the model had not learned
enough for that Subs segment it was an
overlooked one so these are deeper
issues that are uncovered by drifts so
data drift is definitely uh it's not a
four it can actually help in in making
your model more robust it can improve
its performance and it can definitely uh
point out mistakes that you did while
translating your problem to a machine
learning
solution so okay like text yes it's
pretty exciting and uh I worked a bit
with monitoring of NLP models as well so
how does those shift look like so we
have the text coming in and a lot of
problems are done there summarization or
sentiment analysis Q&A uh so what
happens is that there are meta features
that are associated with your text uh
when sentiment is one uh you can have
subjectivity whether the person is being
very factual while writing the text or
they too involved with it uh then text
complexity that is the readability of
the text and presence of autov
vocabulary words and the language itself
so these are the meta features of the
text that can can also vary over time or
due to change of the Upstream processes
for instance you have exposed a chart
agent firstly it was working in a
certain demography in a small space now
you have expanded your operations your
service is exposed to a larger number of
people uh people who may not be native
English speakers so again uh the this
change in the properties uh that can
definitely uh cause a shift a
distribution shift
uh then again I've also seen uh
embeddings DFT as well so the embeddings
of the training
data uh versus the edings of the live
data they can be compared uh that's a
very easy
way and a very quick visual that you can
get of uh such
shifts uh and then again uh some points
where uh unstructured data changes uh
compared to the numerical and
categorical features is that that
usually uh it remains same uh in English
a carrot would remain carrot or a set of
synonyms but it would not go off too
much uh whereas when you're talking
about numbers yes they can vary a lot
especially if you're talking about
numerical features they have a bigger
space to vary over uh again uh do check
for
integrity isues and
outliers you or you can look for uh
outliers in terms of the frequency of
the language
that your service is seeing or how is
the complexity of the text varying over
time uh such uh outlier checks they
really
help and how the incoming data they
stand against each other and again yeah
did any external factors change or
not so I guess uh this was it of about
the talk and do uh get in touch if you
have any queries and I guess I'll just
open the floor to
Q&A awesome thank you so much goth that
was that was phenomenal um I'm looking
in the chat now it doesn't look like
there's
any any questions quite yet so again I'm
going open up the stage to all the
audience um if there's anything that's
pending or anything that you'd like to
uh get clarified here's your opportunity
in the Q&A if you drop them we can go
ahead and read them out loud and get you
some answers to
that okay uh let me just share should I
share the link of the collab over here
only yeah that would be awesome okay
just
the okay that's the block
post
still not seeing independent questions I
guess you did that good of a job you
explain everything so well there's
nothing
people it might be the other way around
you never
know there might be an absolute
po I like to think I like to think of
best case scenario did did did too good
of a
job
thanksa the example
um it looks like we might have a
question which libraries do you find
most
helpful uh it would be a conflict of
interest because we ourselves are
developing uh the solution and U I
personally find yes evidently it's
pretty good 9 ml is also pretty nice uh
you can check it
out got the ball roll with one let's see
if we can uh great talk here that the
drift
tax all right so this says we have
another one you indicate that the drift
tax data is much less than
yeah yes so uh when I was talking about
that drift is less uh I meant that the
text is much less prone to drift for
like I give the example that cat and at
Max there can be typos in it or synonyms
in it uh it wouldn't be like that the
word would gain another meaning or it
would another word would replace scat so
that is one thing uh but yes sentiment
can change with time and therefore
watching for drift on sentiment that is
also important because that means that
the service maybe it is getting buggy it
is getting laggy people are not happy
people are starting to abuse so when I
talk
watching metadata that of toxicity and
uh abusive birds so uh that again while
we are protecting the system we are
putting gu guard guidance against it but
definitely watching over it as well so
that we see that okay is there going to
be any uh shift in how much abuse or the
abuse or B words the system was seeing
earlier and with time if it's getting
worse so uh pretty much analogous to
this is the complexity of text that is
coming in again that can also be watched
so that your model is not thrown of
guard I hope that answers your
question